new this morning spring is in full swing
and even as it gets hotter you can still
have a flourishing Desert Garden without
using all the water that Sherry was
talking about Lauren and Grady joins us
live this morning from Sweet Tomato test
Garden up in Centennial hills to work on
her Green Thumb Lauren good morning to
you
good morning yes that's right we are
getting our green thumbs whether you got
a green thumb or black thumb talking
about some tips here to get gardening
joined by Kate Smith of the porch pepper
project now Kate what are some water
conservation things to keep in mind in
our desert small gardens here yes
definitely so you know we do live in a
desert so water is on the Forefront of
the mine there's several different
things that you can do even in your
small space container garden mainly what
you want to do is make that soil into a
sponge and you can do that by what we
talked about earlier creating your own
compost and using organic materials so
that that water is holding inside of the
soil instead of running off you can also
utilize mulches on top of the soil to
combat evaporation and both of those
things together are really going to help
keep the soil moist and keep the plants
thriving we already added that banana in
there the coffee grounds the eggshells
whatnot but let's add a companion plant
one of the things you discuss here in
your book as well so how does that uh
deter pests you were telling me yes so
companion planting is a great first
defense so kind of skip the pesticides
You Can companion plant and this is a
basil plant that we're going to plant in
here with this tomato we'll plop it
right there and the smell of this basil
plant is going to detour pest from
touching Our tomato it's also going to
make our tomatoes taste better too so
it's a win-win scenario perfect and it
smells like you said it smells I wish
there should be a scratch and sniff TV
guys it smells amazing by the way but
you can all find out here in your book
and Shout out your shout out your
website yeah check out small space Urban
desert gardening everything that we've
talked about this morning from how to
get started gardening and growing food
in your small space you can find it my
book porchpepperproject.com thank you so
much for showing us and planting with us
this morning I'll send it back to you
guys from live from Centennial Hills
Lauren negretti 8 news now back to you
guys all right Lauren thank you very
much lots of great resources if you want
to get your gardening going